what did you know you had this gift when
you were in school could you make your
classmates laugh is that when you
figured out great strange thing mmm when
I when I was first born the war just
started second month of the war and then
the the Germans bombed this little town
which caused a lot of puzzlement because
nobody could understand why they'd
wasted perfectly good bombs on a town
like that that's a great town well there
was nothing in my town weston-super-mare
that a bomb could destroy right it could
possibly be as valuable as the bomb and
the Germans dropped a bomb they kind of
lost the economic void my father had
been in the first world war for three
years a brave man he just said I'm
hurting here and a few months later we
were living on a farm but then we went
somewhere else and somewhere else and I
went to twelve different homes in my
first 13 years Wow
so I did him had a chance to what's the
word to kind of get to know sir other
boys or develop proper relations real
friendships yeah so when I went to
school I didn't mix in very well and I
was very awkward and and I began to
discover quite early on that if I could
make the boys laugh you know then
there's a sense of acceptance because
the funny thing is if people think
you're funny
they have affection for it yeah so I
kind of used it as a way in to interpret
what kind of things were you doing in in
say you're in class mm-hmm the professor
or the teacher whoever what are you
doing to get a lot why I had one of it
she got a prop you I I discovered there
was one teacher is particularly dopey
and when he looked at me I would go what
what is that what made that sound
it's a glasses case Oh oh my god like
that yeah it's lovely because every time
he looked at me I just go hmm
[Laughter]
that's fantastic he never figured it out
and never figured it out
I used to wear my glasses upside down
and that used to puzzle him too did he
ever notice did he ever
well he'd at the very beginning of the
term he was teaching me Old Testament if
you believe that the very beginning of
the term when I wore my glasses upset
after the first I remember he looked at
me and stared for some time right and
then went straight on six weeks later he
one day I've been wearing them
upside-down for the whole six weeks to
two lessons a week and he just looked at
me and said please put your glasses on
the right way so understated I love how
understated it is